you know P a lot of people think I'm gay
I think you are I think you're bisexual
listen I think Ari Shaffir is too I
think a lot of you think are you nervous
I mean I stopped watching
I've stopped watching porn because I
didn't like a guy's dick I don't know
what that means
yeah yeah that might mean something so
you think that I'm bisexual yeah you
think Ari Shaffir is I do jo koy what
are you thinking I I don't know Joe
enough to uh to make a call on and we
throw some other names in there that we
wouldn't know steven is is he ah or not
I haven't gotten that they burn they
haven't gotten that Nell so it's
straight is going s or B I think he's I
like this game say s RB I know he's not
gay because we banged a chick at the
same time yeah and like he stayed way on
his side and I stayed way on my saw I've
been in that situation today like hey
dude we're both yeah you begin some
right now but I don't need the cross
streams right now yeah yeah Wow yeah so
that was with him - yeah believable
Calland I think he was an interesting
guy
it's not that I think he's bi I just
think he's so horny that my ass please
try some guys that try it he'll try
anything yeah difference but Andy Dick
is the opposite of that worry I'll just
stick anything in his mouth nothing is
what G what's that gay then I think he's
both yeah yeah but extreme B and G yeah
yeah yeah but this game is fascinating
to me yeah yeah who else
let me see who are you more mm-hmm so if
he's bisexual do you think he's into
women more than he is men who Bobby
Bobby
I think he's into more he's into women
more yes for sure I don't know it
doesn't it doesn't bother me I don't
care what the [ __ ] he wants yeah his
life Oh L magical straight as far as
[ __ ] - [ __ ] what does that say it's
really what Bobby Lee Wikipedia
bisexual that's on Wikipedia
that's on Wikipedia
but you're listed in the Internet as a
bisexual man what did you announce this
when did you announce this I mean he
talks about sucking dick on everybody
here the face of the LGP you're so free
now high school actually meant I was a
dude yeah I've you know like apps dude
they keep working out the kinks you just
stop I say something on group level and
I'm gonna be completely and utterly
honest with everyone in this room all
right
I believe that I'm not bisexual I
believe that I'm completely heterosexual
but flexible I'm not only that nobody
here's what it is I like I want them
like you know gay people and you know
people that have you know a different
sexual identity right I want to you know
mean support them and I want to you know
encourage them and I like it I like the
whole I say something about it right
that maybe and also in high school I
would let a hot [ __ ] suck my dick that
I would do I'm just gonna tell you that
I'm not you leave me alone okay I'm not
gonna leave you on this island some of
these chicks they're pretty [ __ ] hot
and the dick doesn't care I don't care
so I'm not I know flexible I know a
comic that's seeing you know me a [ __ ]
I think he's already talked about it I
know but I just want to stand under his
name
pretty big common New York City yeah
yeah yeah yeah he showed me a photo over
and I'm like I went yeah yeah yeah but
what is that so then you're bisexual
I'm hetero flexible flexible yeah we had
a hot [ __ ] suck my dick but I'm not
gonna be like cruising for dudes Rio
right just like tricks for brain I know
if that [ __ ] goes um I'm gonna suck
your dick
yeah and then she's like
well you want to [ __ ] me in the butthole
that probably not be real you're in
you're half hard your mother you're
about to come right and she bends over
it's a nice but halls the most beautiful
buttholes yeah yeah it's I mean come
here take care of it
yeah I mean holes a hole dude that's a
there we go I love it
we went so many quotes today holes a
hole holes a hole
oh well as a whole is it not yeah yeah
[Music]